our next guest is very familiar with
that not so pretty Skyline this morning
a little bit rainy out there Native New
Yorker and three-time Academy Award
nominee Sigourney Weaver is best known
for well take your picks and break their
role in alien in 1979 she's appeared in
so many movies that you know and love
we're talking Ghostbusters we're talking
Avatar Gorillas in the Mist working girl
I could go on you probably are on your
own head her new movie It's called call
Jane Weaver Stars alongside Elizabeth
Banks and Weaver plays a character named
Virginia inspired by the leader of a
real life secret group of women who work
to provide abortions in 1960 Chicago
that would be before the landmark Roe v
Wade decision in this clip Virginia
Works to convince Banks's character joy
to keep working with the group
yeah it's not perfect but it works and
since you just stopped answering your
phone I have a hundred women lined up
waiting for the doctor and you're it you
are all I have
you are all we have
come on you can't just
garden and go to your PTA meetings
that's not the joy I know
wow Sigourney Weaver joins us now uh
thank you very much for being here this
movie is on can Elite well time to the
point where when I first watched it I
thought how did they make it so quickly
yeah that's such a good point but how
did how did the meaning of the film
change as the national political and
legal picture changed
well I remember it was difficult for us
to find a state in which to film call
Jane I didn't really think about it at
the time
um but I think it was so foreshadowing
of the overturning of Roe versus Wade
we filmed in Connecticut in the end when
when so that was 2021. okay so States
would look at the script or the ideas in
the film and say yeah we don't want that
we don't want that kind of film wow so
uh we were also making it for about 25
cents that might have had something to
do but anyway it's I was alive during uh
pre-roe versus Wade
um and uh what's interesting to me is
that the landscape has changed a lot in
terms of women's access to medication
um but uh you know I think of this as
Women's Health Care yeah basic Women's
Health Care and um so women don't have
to provide abortions for other women now
but it's now they're criminalizing
anyone who helps a woman trying to get
abortion and criminalizing the woman too
yes so the polls all show that most
people in the country are where you are
on this issue they support a woman's
right to some access uh and yet the
issue is very divisive people who are
opposed are extremely opposed were you
concerned in taking on this role and and
making this movie that that could lead
to issues you know I respect other
people's points of view
um
completely and uh you know
and so I I feel that it certainly is a
subject that we're now all talking about
and um I think that that's
very healthy you know it's part of life
the movie got to me because it just
struck a chord with the decisions that
we have to make and what we women as
women people had to go through they're
saying you and Elizabeth Banks are
calling your performances stand out we
totally agree two thumbs up for you no
thank you but but what did this role
mean to you personally as you're doing
reading the script and you're acting it
out did it make you think I'm not even
talking about your own life but what did
it mean to you personally to play this
this character well you know I loved
Virginia
right away I think she she was a you
know a lifelong activist in the anti-war
protest but I think women were largely
sidelined by the men there so finally
Virginia has found this
is behind this organization that she
really believes in she runs it well yeah
and she's I think quite a great leader
you know she just this is like a
Sisterhood of women taking care of other
women and I think it's very touching in
that way and Elizabeth plays a housewife
who who for health reasons has to
get an abortion and our group uh is
there for her and the callous doctor is
not really a doctor at one point
describes it as scooping seeds out of a
pumpkin and I just thought just to
relegate it to that right yeah
when you walked in there were Whispers
we're all fans but then they were
followed by whispers about your pen and
it says bans off our bodies and it's
powerful yeah
um why did you decide to wear that and
why did you decide to use your voice for
topics like this yeah
well
um we were co-sponsored by Planned
Parenthood at our Premiere in LA and
they gave us these pins bands off our
bodies uh I don't think
I don't think most people want the
government involved in their very
personal choices about their health and
their lives
um and I think that was
I mean I just feel
such a connection with the women we took
care of in the movie and you know with
what's going on now women need our
protection and our support to go through
what is really a serious crisis well now
think of this idea that that if people
want to stop abortion which no one wants
abortions to happen that we're focusing
on the wrong gender we should be
focusing on the men uh because men cause
night they cause 100 of all unwanted
pregnancies and unwanted pregnancies are
yeah well I think that's very refreshing
to hearing you say that because that is
true
um people don't men should be more
involved in this yes yeah absolutely um
and those of us who have sons need to
make sure that they're aware of that can
I just ask you about Avatar are you are
you as excited about that as the rest of
the world yeah the rest of the people on
the planet are well
um I'm sure I will be in November when
we start to promote it around the world
no it's it was a it's it's a great story
a story about family and you're happy
with how it turned out I haven't seen it
of course
I did it I lived through it all that
underwater diving
um so I am as excited as any of you to
see in fact you know well we can't wait
for that I'm excited
so good I'm excited for people to see
call Jane uh it's going to take people
back to a time in this country that
feels closer than it should of course
and speaking of that Carl Jane hits
theaters on Friday so Courtney Weaver
thank you so much for joining us my
pleasure we appreciate you